what are the options open to Ukraine and
the West I guess as well to to get uh
grain out well if they're going to get
big amounts of grain out of Odessa which
is as you say 20 million tons at least
is backed up there in Odessa then
they've got to have Russian agreement to
do it and there are mines in the in the
area both Ukraine and Russia have laid
mines at least two or three hundred each
it seems so there's probably five or six
hundred mines in the area that's not a
big problem they can be you can clear
channels through them but it won't work
unless Russia agrees Russia won't agree
I'm sure unless they get relief from
sanctions considerable relief they used
it as a bargaining chip they won't get
it so I don't think those talks are
going to go very far but meanwhile
there's something else quite interesting
going on at Ismail which is the port
right down in the southwest the extreme
Southwest of Ukraine which is the port
that serves the Danube and yesterday
eight grain carriers turned up at
Ishmael now there is some danger of
drifting mines coming down there some
danger but not too great but those eight
uh grain carriers are going up the
Danube there is a a channel a bistreya
channel which the ukrainians used to be
silted up the ukrainians have unsilted
it they've dredged it and they've opened
the channel so now Ishmael is a port
that can served the whole of the Danube
which the river goes right up into
Northwest Europe so they can get some of
the Grain in smaller ships maybe 10 000
tons they can get it up to some of their
European customers doesn't solve the
main problem but it does indicate that
now the ukrainians are in control of
snake island the Russians are not on
Snake Island which is opposite is male
which is just down here somewhere 40
kilometers off the coast
um now that that's back in Ukrainian
hands Ismail is a safeish port and some
grain carriers are now working up the
Danube to take grain to Europe as I say
it's a very interesting development
won't solve the problem but it actually
it dares the Russians to interfere with
it it says look this is something
Ukraine is doing for themselves these
are neutral ships taking grain to their
customers you dare to interfere with
them that's in a way it puts the owners
back on the Russians really interesting
uh development there Professor let's
talk now a little bit about the the
broader military developments what's the
latest aerofocus yeah not much movement
on the ground because both sides are
pausing uh as they build up their forces
for what will be the next development
which is the attack on Sally and
chromatosk which is in the western part
of uh the donbass but
um this the battle of the himas goes on
which is the Ukrainian multiple launch
rocket systems they've then got a few of
them but my goodness they're making them
count and so they're attacking Russian
command centers and ammunition dumps so
a couple of days ago at uh novakovka
down near kirshan there was this massive
um ammunition dump explosion and then
last night a big explosion an ammunition
dumping luhansk Luhan City and this is
the first time luhansk has been attacked
since the beginning of the war it's held
by Russian separatists but these himar
Rockets these multiple launch because
they're so accurate that when they hit
the ammunition dump they don't hit
anything else so there's no not much
danger of Civilian casualties and last
night with rockets fired from bakmut
which is quite near the front line the
ukrainians targeted a big ammunition
dump in luhansk so again the Russians
can't do very much about it and what the
ukrainians are doing and they're
degrading Russian ammunition stocks
they're running down their ability to
keep feeding shells into their artillery
the Russians rely a lot on artillery the
Ukraine is doing quite a lot to
neutralize that whether they've done
enough we don't know but they're
certainly slowing down the movement of
Russian forces as this next phase of the
attack develops Professor my clock as
always thanks so much